hello and welcome to zero playing FMS
m3m from japan it seems ok got a very
soft not very frequent frequently seen
opening oh wow it's been a while since I
looked at this it is so very very ok for
lucky but it's the kind of thing you
look at it like once and then forget
everything ok so how does that actually
go the problem here's the development is
his belly developed and sometimes white
manages some some quick attacks with
stuff to be five and then or d 5 mm-hmm
I absolutely don't remember and I don't
remember at all how does this play ok
that doesn't look over very scary to be
honest maybe I have something better
actually what about this and then Bishop
g7 maybe yeah this is a bit more bit
more active
what will quite often castle know and
they'll try to do something click on the
D file this happened to me I've lost
against the stuff but not exactly like
this but against the style of playing
yeah where is he going a queen to a
formerly to c4 okay looks like a very
time-consuming business ok so what to do
Bishop g7 not sure about it
maybe just castle the castle longs not a
not so bad at least he cannot cancel all
so em I'm a paw down which is which is
something to not forget have to take
care about that so I'm try to get this
Bishop here
no chief for us also on I'll show up a
six is necessary or not but
check okay so all the way to e3 then
looks fairly active here this pollution
but how to how to continue down don't
quite see how I get this pawn back which
still would be nice to do Bishop age six
and maybe this is not actually not that
bad roped into will group teacher
so Bishop c4 yeah maybe yeah this is it
prevented I can't take now and take see
to it ok I have to speed up a little bit
the biggest danger here is to lose on
time so it doesn't do that much probably
him
it's still not that easy for him to
convert the pawn even though and this
cannot be all that great for me either
got some activity but I don't quite see
how to do something great maybe i can
bring the king up on before I have night
c4 which is at least somewhat annoying
that's it's not so easy for me to play
to play them let's see I'm not sure no
it's for something that I had on the
radar but not much I could do about it
so I tried to get to this point and no
Knight c4 I thought would be awkward
be 393 check so i can take it now this
Hanks good time morning check do this
first and now see I can also take him
and go f 6 or something like that and
then I squadra care for I've got this
check though check
it looks awkward night f4 f5 king of 193
check check so I can take this take here
check ya [ __ ] still can and continue to
defy t of course
18 seconds is the problem check play for
mate it's always a good idea if you have
no time on the clock so look see to mate
or jack this one checkmate ok hmm yeah I
kind of forgot I forgot the opening I
checked this like a couple of month ago
and I felt that black is ok but it is
it's not it's tricky it's very very
strange position and now can tend to
forget what is right stockfish here with
not some yeah okay without a reasonable
calculation depth wants to play a 5
which looks kind of logical but ok let's
see how and how it went i don't think
that this was bad here it looks ok
Bishop g7 engine prefers Bishop g7 now
not be should be six yeah maybe this
actually threatens this as screen b5 is
answered with Bishop see three castles
Lord Bishop is six yeah this is stronger
the Queen doesn't have good squares and
something like this is is pretty exact
pretty awful for white this is stop
fishes line with black being in very
good shape
well that was better than I mean this is
ok but it's just compensation 84 porn
and not easy to play yeah I just played
on for for the activity and Jack there's
always some kind of compensation the
bishops are somewhat so strong the night
is annoying you so it's it's something
but not sure how much it actually is so
the to all this is logical the engine
gives me a slight edge now you should be
seven and now ok interesting engine
wants to wants to complete this may I
can mean it's not without its point so
this is very strong and now anchored and
maybe I get one of the two points here
with with this stock fish beliefs on
clearly better okay I didn't really
think about bishop see three hours this
was my plan try to get to the pawn but
it um it's not as good as what the
engine suggested before and I love the
light see form winning and according to
the comp it wants watch to play the head
is smooth no no but it's also not that
great yeah I'm very active here so it is
probably good for me at least in a
practical game yeah check check way
about to see that move check and rookie
tours it's even stronger we had a
stronger this is stronger because he
cannot even do this chat is 95 is
leading to a mate funny enough checkmate
or check checkmate on this one
so rookie to was even stronger ok this
is wins the piece but the other
continuation was was killing immediately
oh here was also something but a night
f1 and engine fines and made what is the
maid are the funky made check and rooks
it to his mate okay headstrong in okay
yeah i was going for them warm check
pedestrian way hampered and now i go go
for check check always good if you have
no time on the clock and I believe that
this year is a good way to play against
the very soft it's not such a super
relevant question what to play against
the various of opening to be honest it's
not played on but this is a thing pretty
powerful um Black is just playing like
he's white it's a stuck into chichi
Goran defends a tempo down and it feels
okay I mean white doesn't have anything
great against it i think this is better
than modest continuations there are
people play 60 or something like that
which is really a little bit a little
bit too tame when you can be active with
this here especially if white wants to
do anything he basically has to take
here at some point yeah and um this
gives black the bishop had always some
long-term thing to play for okay well
thanks for watching